said you can't have fing tacos being
raided by a Mexican restaurant agency
you need tacos eating by a Chinese guy
and see if the Chinese guy likes them
and if he likes them then have some
Italian guy like it okay these tacos are
indeed
[Music]
good all right has anybody been seeing
photos of this guy oh my God coming up
around we found out he's just cake is it
are you for real I don't know someone
made a that video though is it just
paper mâche and then they did a viral
video on it I think that's hilar have
you guys seen the uh the airplane that
like things hovered around and then it
like disappeared what yeah it like it
like teleported what flash you saw it
and I believe them all I believe them
okay I don't know if this is on topic
but if you guys saw a UFO would you go
go up to it hell yeah what do you mean
like the actual if it landed a aircraft
landed I [__] run to it I I would too
I'd run to it but i' I'd run to it and
hide myself I wouldn't because if like
imagine the government shows up too and
then they saw you saw they kill you true
your boy turning around damn I know how
to run and zigzag they can't catch
me they can't [__] catch me dude Nick
and I are going to scope out the place
before we make any decisions holy [__]
Joe's running up to
it he really is former CIA and he was
like on his death bed or something so he
wanted to confess all this [__] back in
like the ' 80s or something like that he
does like a 30-minute interview he talks
about ing all this stuff and how he was
hired and became I think this was the
inspiration for Men In Black the movie
as much as it's like a a scripted like
seemingly non or fictional kind of story
it was they literally were like called
them like men in black or something like
that they had actual machines that would
brainwash people or wi the memory and he
had to go through this whole thing and
he was working with like half human half
aliens like uh species that like had
made it and then they made a deal with
the government to build technology off
of their weaponry and aircrafts and
stuff which is where all of our like
[__] New Age Technology came from in
return the aliens were able to do
experiments by abducting [__] people
and [__] I know that sounds like a good
deal I sound like the [__] movies I
think that's a good deal kind of be nice
if they could figure out a way to make
cars you know more gas efficient yeah
can they help us out with more stuff is
I saw someone in like the ' 80s or '90s
they figured out how to power a car with
water but it's all about money so they
don't do it yeah no they got the tech
for it they got it from the aliens
anyways this month [__] cake guy over
here right um this has been Sur just
coming around on the internet because
basically just over a week ago a uh it
this was in Mexico that they had a
public hearing where alien corpses were
shown to Congress Mexicans Congress
Mexicans Mexico's Congress uh with a UFO
expert who was forced to testify under
oath and brought these [__] alien
corpses from Peru so they displayed
these guys in glass and under oath was
like these are aliens this this made
their Congress look so bad though why
not real aliens you're like what the
[__] like you don't guys got no fact
Checkers and [__] you're for sure like
these aren't aliens [__] no like [__]
ET that looks like a ashy ET yesterday
they um he's like shrunken maybe it's
with the bones or the the flesh it's
like I don't know it looks like [__]
there's a team that fake aliens in
Mexico that recently it came out
yesterday that they basically ran tests
on them said like DN don't match human
they say that like it hasn't been you
know constructed by human hands or
whatever but then also everybody else
outside of Mexico and say is saying like
why don't you let a third party test it
why is it all being done by your circle
and also like when this was first coming
out the guy that broke it out they're
saying like that guy's a proven con
artist yeah he's definitely has some
stuff that's been debunked before that's
what I'm saying you can't have [__]
taco
being raided by a Mexican restaurant
agency you need tacos eaten by a Chinese
guy and see if the Chinese guy likes
them and if he likes them then have some
Italian guy like it okay these tacos are
indeed good but if you have the same
people rating the same [__] yeah that's
[__] what is that called nepotism
backwards cuz it cuz it's their family
member
specifically National nepotism National
yeah they like inside [__] bases yeah
that's called America
that's like Biden and Hillary Clinton
you know what I mean they said these
specimen are not part of our terrestrial
Evolution and these aren't beings that
were found after a UFO record wreckage
they were found in uh algae mines and
were later fossilized so apparently or
theoretically these guys came from like
a long long time ago that were here a
long long time ago and were fossilized
in mines that were like deep in the
earth I believe it you think it's alien
there's two of them I do think for sure
aliens exist no that's not the question
brother I'm asking you do I think this
is a real alien yeah you think those
[__] two pinatas are aliens or you
know what's funny though do you do you
ever think it's like one of those hide
and plain sites like like we joke around
because this [__] looks like ET
so like of course that's fictional
because we've only ever understood ET as
a fictional where the red hoodie dude
thing right but do you ever think that
they're like yeah how are we going to
hide this thing yeah let's put it in
plain sight let's make it look exactly
like it so every single time somebody
sees some sort of alien they're just
like this is [__] because seen in
the movies or the same concept as like
if this CIA dude I was talking about was
for real like there was a whole men and
black thing they're like yeah let's make
a movie called men and black with where
it does exactly what they say concept is
to hide the thing in plain sight yeah
you know what I mean like wouldn't that
make a lot of sense that is like CIA
disinformation campaigns is what they do
yeah so that's why I'm like immediately
it's like oh dude this looks like ET
yeah of course it's [__] I hope it's
real what what if that's the whole point
yeah like that really is what aliens
look like does anyone here know what an
algae mine is no I don't even know what
an algae mine is I don't know either but
they found it there yeah what is an
algae mine you mine algae mhm algae is
just in the ocean that's what I'm saying
but they found it in an algae mine I
thought mines were like [__] for
stones and coal and gold and [__] that's
like I found it in the tofu cave
yeah tofu cave don't ask too many
questions bro it's a silk and
tofu medium firm I don't know what that
is a algae
[Laughter]
and another thing is why are there no no
photos of the discovery like wouldn't it
make national news of like people at the
algae mine like taking photos of like we
found this [__] threefoot [__] there
was a court hearing already like last
month of this guy that was used to be in
the um the government and he like
basically like had he he proved
everything that was like aliens are
existed and all this stuff since like
the 80s or whatever oh the guy was in
the Navy right I think so there's there
I think it's it's called the disclosure
project but there's like 300 plus
government agents that had a convention
and every single one of them were like
yeah you guys need to just come out cuz
and then everyone was talking about
their personal experience whether in the
military different branches of
government I think it's crazier to not
think that aliens aren't real you're
calling him crazy I think they're real
oh turning around now huh just not those
[__] fake ass all of a sudden flers
those are [__] Pez dispensers think
you don't think an alien would look like
that n big old bra what do you think
they look like that sh look like a
pinata dude yeah well I mean they're
going to look like something different
did you hear those two dudes on Joe
Rogan that are like super into like
aliens or journalists what do they say
so he was say I think what they're
saying is right now the problem with why
people can't like cuz we they you see
like guys like him like
testify but there's so many like strings
of Black Ops like the government will
create a Black Ops Secret Agency to
study aliens and then they have another
secret Black Ops agency another Black
Ops another Black Ops so when one person
comes out the only way for them to truly
reveal what's happening they have to
blow this person's cover but then to
corroborate that this person has to blow
this person's cover so for them they're
like we actually can't fully come out
unless we all come out but then no one's
going to all come out cuz some people
are still tied and in and so now I think
they're like the only way for this to go
down is if like from the top they have a
fullon audit to see where all the
spending is actually going and it's just
it's like imagine Navy Seals had Navy
Seals had Navy Seals had Navy Seals and
I even know like there's like probably
agency that's been running for 70 years
that no one even knows about oh for sure
which is [__] crazy and then that
would be funny if they all investigate
each other thinking that they're like
the bad guys but then they're just like
yeah it's like the FBI CIA they're all
like looking into each other's programs
and [__] they're like these guys are
[__] a a secret gang with aliens
but it's just them it's just government
agencies it's their co-workers yeah it's
all [__] each other up like to
entertain the theory or the notion that
uh one if aliens were able to come here
it's probably because they are a
technologically advanced species and
then that like kind of like backs up
those you know uh Egyptian pyramid
theories it backs up like technology
over the last like [__] 50 years and
are are spiking understanding random
[__] that like how the [__] humans
really I know we're smart or intelligent
in some way but like how the [__] did we
accomplish certain things or like
exponentially improve our technological
understanding of certain stuff it's like
well if we got help or if we got
something to study that definitely makes
it a lot more plausible you know and if
there's going to be [__] aliens
that we have an entire like culture
around it you know what I mean and
that's a kind of a cohesive
understanding whether they look like a
certain thing like ET whether there's
like this area 51 or Roswell situation
whether there's like UFOs that are like
[__] in all these like Army Navy
[__] Air Force you know what I mean
there's a there's a culture around it
that's like semi-consistent it's got to
be real can't my thing is like why are
they so shy I feel like they lowkey
could even like portray humans
shapeshifting ass aliens I feel like
they have if they have technology like
that they already said they're half
alien half humans that walk among us or
I people look alien though dude like
who I'm just saying once in a while like
name one famous person n it's just
people like you see a Chinese person
walking down the street you're like you
look kind of alien sometimes Jack ma
looks like an alien a little bit yo Jack
M looks like a gray alien he look like
he's one of those aliens that his face
come off and a little dude inside yeah
and the little dude inside is this
[__] little little corpse oh that's
what it looks like there are people out
there like you got some alien DNA some
people just don't make sense look like
that on that same thing I feel like low
key like mermaid like I feel like all
these like things that people like think
are fiction I feel like it comes from
somewhere like an alien mermaids are
beluga whales we all know that already
mermaids are just horny Pirates they're
just horny sailor think there's an at
Atlantis you mean no Atlantis is
different Atlantis isn't about Ming
Atlantis was a real place and then it
got [__] submerged Atlantis was in
Africa mhm right the eye what I'm
talking about pretty cool the Sahara
Desert y [__] that's the real deal you
don't know that [__] Atlantis look that
[__] they think they discovered
Atlantis in the West Africa in the
Sahara Desert like where the eye in the
city the eye of Sara desert is actually
the old city of Atlantis that's under
water now no it's it's a desert now used
to be a wet like ocean area that used to
be yes submerged they got like all the
[__] like salt debris and stuff that
was there that's like clearly ocean salt
but like how did how do they travel like
thousands of miles how come you never
mentioned this to us before cuz you
never asked man this is just my thing
all right you know what's crazy so I
used to live in citos and I would dig
for fossils in my backyard as a kid and
I would dig and I would actually find
sea shells in the dirt fire and I'm like
holy [__] this thing used to be
submerged Under the Sea imagine your mom
just putting them there for you
good it's like oh bar has a nice hobby
he mixed with the soil when they made
the
house